dans la pharmacie un secteur en plein
développement
c'est l'homme et aux pets et sur ce
secteur est bien une entreprise moyennes
se développent crée des emplois
les laboratoires boiron années 80 la
médecine douce et l'homéopathie sont en
plein boom
ces petites granules ont remboursé à
l'époque à hauteur de 65 % par la
sécurité sociale vont profiter à une
entreprise française une laboratoires
boiron ou laboratoires boiron où servait
d'une mode non nous laboratoires boiron
nous ne nous servons pas d'une mode nous
l'homéopathie à un développement
actuellement du fait des recherches
scientifiques qui ont été faites
effectivement du fait d'un besoin et des
médecins et des patients d'avoir de plus
en plus recours à des thérapeutiques qui
sont dites
12 c'est à dire moins agressive que les
thérapeutiques traditionnel lancée par
deux frères jumeaux en 1967 à lyon
repris par un des fils christian boiron
l'entreprise connaît une croissance
impressionnante six voix sur 5 ans à peu
près ou sur six ans on a dû presque
doubler les effectifs
l'entreprise devient rapidement le
numéro un mondial et ouvre des
laboratoires à l'étranger en italie en
espagne en inde et aux états unis
en 1996 elle fait son entrée en bourse
notre conviction et nos analyses nous
montre que l'homéopathie devrait dans
les prochaines années se développer
d'une façon assez considérable en france
et sur le plan international
ceci nous amène automatiquement avoir
besoin de capitaux le laboratoire
continue sur sa lancée et son chiffre
d'affaires ne fait qu'augmenter 160
millions d'euros en 1992 ces deux 185,3
millions en 2003 2003 une date qui
aurait pu freiner le développement du
laboratoire
cette année là le ministre de la santé
entend les critiques qui sont faites à
l'homéopathie et décident d'abaisser le
taux de remboursement à 35 %
premières victimes les laboratoires
boiron leader mondial du marché de
l'homéopathie à chauray les 32 salariés
du site ne cachent pas leur inquiétude
malgré cette baisse de prise en charge
le chiffre d'affaires a continué
d'augmenter dans les années suivantes
passant à 617 7 millions d'euros en 2013
mais depuis quelques années l'entreprise
connaît une certaine stagnation de son
chiffre d'affaires en début d'année 2010
9 christian voir on craignait un
déremboursement total qui selon lui
menacerait les emplois de son entreprise
[Musique]